everybody Peter Martin here for gamespot
with an e 3 news update Nintendo's
digital event is kicked off and Martin
Zelda was the most exciting thing in
that tell me what did you say it's it's
one of the most exciting things of the
whole goddamn show like so you've only
seen I mean I'm sure you know you'll be
there as well we've seen my like 20 30
seconds 40 you see this this wide sort
of sweeping Vista you get all these
tantalizing hints about it being an
open-world game then you get an action
shot with some weird monster thing
chasing them yeah I need on the back of
a poner and it's got a bit of a cape on
and it comes off and he ties the phone
oh right looks incredible it's
incredible and it's not an outs for next
year which makes me real sad what's left
for me to say I know my honor okay so
essentially what Nintendo is saying is
that they're trying to bring the Zelda
series back to the original design of
the game where you can pretty much go
anywhere that you could as long as you
can survive right yeah so because of
that the world is filled with you know
easy monsters and difficult monsters
wherever you're going to go it's sort of
breaking the new model for Zelda yep and
returning to that but with a visual
design that you were describing is it's
just kind of breathtaking you've got
those vistas there are the landscape is
you know it dips it rises their streams
everywhere and I've not seen Hyrule that
interesting in a long time oh it looks
beautiful right the thing I'm game yeah
it looks too beautiful for Wii U game
right here now like it looks so good you
think and the way you do that he's gonna
add to next year it's not so next year
but I know I've shown a couple people
and it was saying that looks too good to
be a Wii Nintendo has ever really done
that before ever well they've not said a
press in your right they've never said
the best thing window together in the
past it just it's a great-looking demo
it's a shame we can't see more but um
god damn it look good it did alright
that's Delta thanks for watching
everybody sent you in a game spot for e3
2014 updates i'm peter is Martin thanks
for watching
you